-One of my favorite things
about the book is --
and your tenure now at "SNL" --
It has been so long,
and I had a great time
writing with you over the years.
And I'm such a fan
of your writing.
And you talk about a lot
about of your favorite sketches.
You have created
some real indelible characters.
Drunk Uncle,
one of my all-time favorites.
And I should note you created
two with Bobby Moynihan.
The other being Anthony
Crispino, Second Hand News.
-Second Hand News, yeah.
-Did you come up with
Drunk Uncle first
or did you see Bobby and think
that he would be good
at being a drunk uncle?
He's obviously perfect at it.
-He's like a deep -- It's one of
the best acting performances
you'll see on our show
'cause it's live.
And he's finding all these
different registers so quickly
and all these
different emotions.
I had come up with the concept
of Second Hand News.
And I was like,
"What about Second Hand News?"
And then he had the voice.
He just had the like,
"Yeah, I don't know about that."
Like that kind of -- which is
a pure performance thing
that gave it
a whole other dimension.
With Drunk Uncle, he came to me
and was like,
"Two words -- drunk uncle.
I don't know what it is.
Is there something?"
And I was like, "I think there's
something there."
And then figuring out, like,
you know, what the hell it was.
But it was -- He was just like,
"I just thought
that was a funny phrase."
And the weird thing is when you
do that sketch, you know,
Bobby and I both have uncles.
So, of course,
their first question is,
"Now, is this based on me
in some way?
I know I kind of
go for it on Thanksgiving.
But I can hold back most days."
And so the first question's
kind of like, "Are we okay?"
-From your uncles. Yeah.
You also wrote Cecily Strong's
"the girl you wish you hadn't
started a conversation with
at a party."
I think I said it right.
It's maybe the longest character
name in the history of "SNL."
-I think almost no one,
even fans of the character,
know what the character's
called.
I think Michael Che said
that his mom calls it
"the girl who's always wrong."
[ Laughter ]
-That's not bad.
-Something like that.
And I was like, "Yeah, that's
pretty -- that's maybe better."
-That was one of the more --
I mean, I think people forget --
I think that was the first thing
Cecily did on the show.
And it's one of the most,
like, bravura performances
I've ever seen.
-I remember in --
I write about it in the book,
but I remember being with you
afterwards.
Like, when you got offstage and
you had just done it with her.
Like, been out there
and just seen the character
for the first time.
And we had a moment afterwards
where we were both kind of
in awe of her performance
'cause you just don't see
someone who's brand new
at the show hit it like --
just knock it
out of the ballpark
in that specific,
very fine-tuned way.
And the confidence --
-Yeah.
-It was really special.
-I think there was a moment
where she glanced
in her purse at a phone.
There was some sort of physical
moment that I just thought,
"Who can also do this?"
-Yeah. Own a small physical
movement in the middle of
this big character piece
on your first --
one of your first shows
at "SNL."
And the move --
Yeah, you're right.
I remember she looked
and put the phone --
and just with perfect precision
and ease.
-Yeah.
It was like, oh, there --
She threw a perfect game
her first time on the mound.
It was amazing.
-Yes, it really is.
I think that's
the right analogy.
Like, it was like throwing
a perfect game your first game.
-It's such a fun book.
But that is one of my favorite
things about it,
is over the years on this show,
and again, I don't think
a ton of people know this.
You've done such a great job of
identifying what's really funny
about cast members
and writing to that voice.
And I think
it's the most important thing
for a writer on that show.
And you're just so good at it,
buddy.
-I mean, I learned
a lot from you.
Like so many people who wrote
at the show in the time
when you were head writer,
you helped me tremendously.
And I learned about writing
for people from you.
And you would write a scene
where basically
every cast member had a part.
And it would be
their funniest character
that they never got on the show
in some other way,
like Fred's Mets character,
where he just --
I remember one sketch you wrote
that was about people
brainstorming themes for a prom.
And Fred looks like
he's a 45-year-old man
with a mustache
in a Mets' jacket
at a high school prom
theme meeting who is just like,
"What about the Mets?
The Mets are pretty cool."
It was like a throw-away thing
he had done in the office
and you made it a starring part
in this sketch.
You were great at it.
-I think we both
would admit to the fact
that we have been incredibly
lucky in our careers
to be surrounded by performers
that elevate every word
you would ever put on the page.
-Yes.
And that is -- that's where you
learn -- I certainly --
you learn your own limitations
and then you see someone else
that can do these things
that you cannot.
And you're, like, "Ooh, that's
exciting to write for that --
write for that person's voice"
and get to do things
that you can't do yourself.
-Well, buddy, obviously nobody
knows what the future holds,
but I'm looking forward
to hopefully the fall
and "SNL" and you at the desk.
And congrats on the book, and
it's always the best to see you.
-Thank you.
It is wonderful to see you.
I was trying to figure out
some elaborate scam
when you had an attic door still
of who I could hire
to be in there and jump out
halfway through and scare you.
[ Laughs ]
But it turns out it's hard
to hire street performers
who will travel to remote places
during a quarantine
to scare people.
-To violate pandemic rules
for the purposes of a laugh?
-And then also hard to convince
wives to let a stranger
hide in a crawl space
for a day before a show.
-Oh, no, no.
My wife loves all your ideas.
-[ Laughs ]
They love -- All of our wives
love your ideas the most.
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright. I love you, buddy.
-I love you.
It's great to see you.